vlad you've changed chairs what do you
got dancing in the moonlight a little
dancing in the moonlight because we're
getting our very first color look at
distant worlds from the james webb space
telescope nasa called it the deepest
image of the universe we have ever seen
look how stunningly beautiful this is so
what you're looking at is a cluster of
stars and galaxies from just a slice of
the vast universe webb doesn't just
explore a galaxy far far away it
actually looks back in time why because
the image shows light from more than 13
billion years ago it takes that long for
the light to travel to our eyes to our
eyes where we are here on planet earth
so keep in mind if you're looking up at
the night sky what you're seeing in this
image represents a spot about the size
of a grain of sand
nasa plans to release the rest of the
telescope's never before seen images
later today isn't this one
i stare at this and i'm just thinking
this is the vast universe which we are a
part of yeah
i think the best way to understand it is
it's like baby pictures of the universe
right so the big bang happens and then
the the universe is a toddler this is a
toddler shot of the universe that's how
astronomers see this yeah very much so
very very cool